- [Woman] Do you see any trends
for me to use with my students
to connect with parents?
- [Gary] My most practical
advice to a sixth grade teacher
is to try to build
the self-esteem
of the students in your class.
That would be, that is the thing
I spend my entire
life thinking about
which is the only tool
against all the pressures
that our kids
face is self-esteem.
That is the weapon.
And so I only had one
teacher ever that I saw
now rewinding my brain and
realizing what she was doing
that went person
by person in her class
and accelerated and celebrated
their unique
individual strengths.
Whether it was sports, school,
personality, humor,
kindness, prettiness,
whatever it was
she built self-esteem
and that's why I remember her.
(light music)